This is the 99% of visible breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elizabeth Joe. Today we are discussing Article 5, which lays out the ways to amend the Constitution. And from the beginning of this series, we knew there was only one person we wanted to have for this episode, historian and writer Jill Lepore. Jill is an American history professor at Harvard, a staff writer at The New Yorker, and author of one of my favorite books, Bees Truths, a history of the, United States. This fall she published a new book, We the People, a history of the U.S. Constitution, and Jill tells the history of the Constitution through amendments, ones that
这是对宪法可见运作机制99%的剖析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是伊丽莎白·乔。今天我们讨论的是第五条，它规定了修改宪法的方法。从本系列一开始，我们就知道这一集我们只想请一位嘉宾，那就是历史学家兼作家吉尔·莱波雷。吉尔是哈佛大学美国历史教授、《纽约客》特约撰稿人，也是我最喜欢的书之一《蜂后真相：美国史》的作者。今年秋天，她出版了一本新书《我们人民：美国宪法史》，吉尔通过修正案讲述了宪法历史，包括那些
succeeded and ones that failed. Article 5 is just one long sentence. One long, boring sentence. Here it is. The Congress, whenever two-thirds of both houses, shall deem it necessary, shall propose amendments to this Constitution, or on the application of the legislatures of two-thirds of the several states shall call a convention for proposing amendments, which in either case, shall be valid to all intents and purposes as part of this constitution when ratified by the legislatures of three-fourths of the several states, or by conventions in three-fourths thereof, as one or the other mode of ratification may be proposed by the Congress. Provided that no amendment shall be made prior to the year 1,808, shall in any manner
成功的修正案和失败的修正案。第五条只有长长的一句话。长而又枯燥的一句话。内容如下。国会认为两院三分之二认为必要时，应提出本宪法的修正案，或者应三分之二各州议会的申请，应召集会议以提出修正案，无论在哪种情况下，当获得四分之三各州议会或四分之三各州会议的批准时，对于所有意图和目的而言，该修正案即告有效，成为本宪法的一部分，具体批准方式可由国会提议其中一种。但规定，在1808年之前不得作出的任何修正案，均不得以任何方式
affect the first and fourth clauses in the ninth section of the first. article, and that no state without its consent shall be deprived of its equal suffrage in the Senate. In her book, Jill Lippur argues that the Constitution is designed. It is truly meant to be amended. And before we go any further, it's important to define what a constitutional amendment really is, because the definition is broader than what most people probably think. The word amendment just keeps taking on all these adjectives. So legal scholars like to talk about formal Article 5 amendments. And a formal Article 5 amendment is a constitutional amendment that is properly adopted and ratified into the U.S. Constitution through the methods that are described in Article 5.
影响第一条第九款的第一和第四项，并且未经其同意，不得剥夺任何州在参议院的平等表决权。吉尔·莱波雷在她的书中认为，宪法是经过设计的。它确实是用来被修改的。在我们深入探讨之前，有必要先定义一下什么是真正的宪法修正案，因为这个定义比大多数人想象的要广泛。宪法修正案这个词一直在吸收各种形容词。因此，法律学者喜欢谈论正式的第五条修正案。正式的第五条修正案是指通过第五条所述的方法，被正确采纳并通过并纳入美国宪法的宪法修正案。
But because an amendment just really means a change or revision or a correction or repair, and because the Constitution is changing and being corrected, repaired, and altered all the time, amendment happens in other ways. And so then legal scholars come up with other adjectives to describe other kinds of amending the Constitution. Informal amendment is a common way of describing a kind of creeping change that comes about almost by habit or practice. And then there are amendments that are often described as de facto amendments that are really judicial decisions that have the consequence of changing how we understand
但由于修正案实际上只意味着更改、修订、纠正或修复，而且由于宪法一直在变化、被纠正、修复和变更，修正案也通过其他方式发生。因此，法律学者们提出了其他形容词来描述修改宪法的其他类型。非正式修正案是描述几乎通过习惯或实践产生的一种潜移默化的改变的常见方式。此外，还有一些修正案通常被称为事实上的修正案，它们实际上是具有改变我们理解某种宪法规定之结果的司法判决。
a provision of the Constitution. We could make more piles than that. I would say those might be the three main ones. Yeah. And just importantly, that when you use that, say that, you mean, for those listeners who might not understand, when the Supreme Court, for instance, I think you're saying, makes a new interpretation of the Constitution, we can consider that an amendment as well, even though the Supreme Court may not say that explicitly. Yeah. So, no matter what your
我们可以列出更多类别。我可以说这可能是三个主要的类别。是的。而且重要的是，当你这样说时，你的意思是，对于那些可能不理解的听众来说，比如说，当最高法院做出对宪法的新解释时，我想你是这个意思，我们也可以认为那是一个修正案，尽管最高法院可能没有明确说出来。是的。所以，无论你的
political preferences, people don't like to admit that the Supreme Court is actually often amending the Constitution. In my observation, you may have a different view of this, because technically the Supreme Court's not supposed to be amending the Constitution. So there's a kind of nudge, nudge, wink, wink when the, you know, when the Supreme Court says, oh, there is such a thing as presidential immunity, in my mind, that's an amendment to the Constitution. Like, that's not in the Constitution. They have invented and devised that. Or when the Supreme Court said, you know, in Griswold v. Connecticut, 1965, there's a right to privacy that extends to birth control for married couples, you know,
政治倾向如何，人们都不愿承认最高法院实际上经常在修改宪法。根据我的观察，你对此可能会有不同的看法，因为从技术上讲，最高法院不应该修改宪法。所以，当最高法院说，哦，存在总统豁免权这种东西时，这就有一种心照不宣、意味深长的暗示，在我看来，这就是对宪法的修正。因为宪法里并没有这一条。这是他们凭空捏造和设计出来的。或者当最高法院在1965年的格里斯沃尔德诉康涅狄格州案中说，存在一项适用于已婚夫妇避孕的隐私权时，你知道的，
said that's not in the Constitution, that's an amendment to the Constitution. Usually when you say something, the court is amending the Constitution, you are denying the legitimacy of the change rather than accepting the legitimacy of the change. Right, right. But the core of your book is actually about the formal part, the formal aspect of amending the Constitution. So could you talk through a little bit about Article 5, the process, why it was included and why does it say specifically what it does?
他们说宪法里没有这一条，这就是对宪法的修正。通常，当你说是法院在修改宪法时，你是在否认这种改变的合法性，而不是接受这种改变的合法性。对，对。但你这本书的核心实际上是关于正式的部分，即修改宪法的正式方面。那么你能否详细讲讲第五条、这个过程、为什么它被包含在内，以及为什么它会具体这样规定？
Yeah. So it was really a new idea, and it doesn't, it's not new to the Constitution of 1787. It's new in the constitutions of 1776. So it's a great time to be talking about this because we think of this 250th anniversary of the country as celebrating 250 years since the Declaration of Independence. But of course, the first state constitutions were adopted in 1776, beginning in January of 1776. And the Declaration of Independence follows from them and, in fact, borrows a fair amount. from them. So the states, the new states, former colonies, had no government when the royal governors fled after the war started in 1775. And they had to make some decisions and do some things. So they
对。所以这真的是一个全新的想法，而且它并不新鲜于1787年的宪法。它在1776年的宪法中就已经很新了。所以现在是谈论这个的好时机，因为我们认为这个国家的250周年庆典是在庆祝自独立宣言以来的250年。但当然，第一批州宪法是在1776年通过的，始于1776年1月。独立宣言紧随其之后，事实上，借鉴了它们相当多的内容。
started forming governments in 1776. And John Adams, who was in the Continental Congress, and they should all write constitutions and they should basically be the same. Because we believe in written constitutions, Adams said, England's constitution is unwritten, but we think the states should write down their constitutions, and people generally also believe those constitutions should include declarations of rights. And increasingly over time, this wasn't by no means the case entirely across the first state constitutions, but increasingly a set of expectations emerged about what a written constitution is in a republic. One, that it has to be written by a specially elected body, like a legislature can't write the Constitution, because they'll
因此，这些州、新州、前殖民地，在1775年战争爆发后皇家总督逃跑后，没有政府。他们必须做出一些决定并采取一些行动。所以他们在1776年开始组建政府。当时在大陆会议上的约翰·亚当斯说，他们都应该编写宪法，而且这些宪法基本应该是一样的。亚当斯说，因为我们信仰成文宪法，英国的宪法是不成文的，但我们认为各州应该把宪法写下来，人们通常也认为这些宪法应该包括权利宣言。随着时间的推移，这种情况并非完全适用于所有最初的州宪法，但在一个共和国里，关于什么是成文宪法的期望逐渐形成。第一，它必须由一个特别选举产生的机构来编写，比如立法机构不能编写宪法，因为他们会
just give themselves too much power. So you have to have a special convention of people who are elected or delegated solely for the purpose of writing constitution. So there has to be a convention so that the Constitution is popularly drafted. Then the Constitution after its draft it has to be sent to the people for their ratification. They have to approve it. Can't become a Constitution unless it's popularly ratified. And then the third idea that emerged as, you know, the third, you know, the leg of the stool of what a written constitution is in the United States is it has to be amendable by the people for the same reason that the legislature can't write it right and that the people have to ratify it if if you really believe that the people are sovereign there's no
给自己赋予太多权力。所以你必须有一个专门的会议，由专门为了编写宪法这一单一目的而选举或委派的人员组成。所以必须有一个会议，这样宪法才是民选草拟的。然后，宪法草拟完成后，必须提交给人民进行批准。他们必须批准它。除非得到民众的批准，否则它不能成为宪法。然后是作为美国成文宪法基石的第三个理念，即人民必须能够对其进行修改。原因与立法机构不能编写宪法以及人民必须批准宪法的原因相同：如果你真的相信人民是主权者，没有一个
king who is sovereign we rule ourselves then we should write fundamental law and if fundamental law needs to change we should be able to change it so this is like the core of constitutionalism in the emerging United States and so those ideas are you know there's been a lot of experimentation like some states adopted constitutions without a convention, some states adopted constitutions with no amendment provision, some states adopted constitutions where the thing could be amended, but the legislature could be amended. And they all kind of failed.
拥有主权的国王，是我们自己在统治自己，那么我们就应该编写根本法，如果根本法需要改变，我们也应该能够改变它。所以这是新兴美国宪政的核心，因此这些想法，你知道，经历了大量的试验，比如一些州在没有会议的情况下通过了宪法，一些州通过的宪法没有修正条款，一些州通过的宪法可以修改，但是由立法机构修改。而它们基本上都失败了。
So there's a big fight in Massachusetts. In 1779, the state assembly legislature writes a constitution and sends it to the towns for ratification, and the people of Massachusetts are like, dude, it's like, no, we're not going to ratify this. Where's the convention? Who told you you could write a Constitution? That's completely crazy.
所以在马萨诸塞州发生了一场大争论。1779年，州议会立法机构编写了一部宪法并提交给各城镇批准，马萨诸塞州的人民说，老兄，这就像是，不，我们不会批准这个。会议在哪里？谁告诉你们可以编写宪法了？这完全是疯了。
No, they just rejected it. And, you know, at the war on, it's a big problem when you don't have a constant. The government has no authority. So they had to hold a constitutional convention in Massachusetts in 1779. The first one was earlier. And the people, among the reasons the towns rejected the Constitution was because the people couldn't amend it either. They didn't write it. They couldn't amend it.
不，他们直接拒绝了。而且，你知道，随着战争的进行，当你没有一部宪法时，这是一个很大的问题。政府没有权威。所以他们不得不在1779年在马萨诸塞州召开一次制宪会议。第一次会议是在更早的时候。而人民之所以拒绝该宪法的其中一个原因，是因为人民也无法修改它。他们没有编写它。他们也无法修改它。
So the new Massachusetts Constitution had an amendment provision. So by the time you get to Philadelphia in 1787, which remember, the reason they're even meeting is because the Articles of Confederation, which the only thing that's holding the United States together, the only way to amend the Articles of Confederation was by the unanimous consent of all the states. And they could never amend them because Rhode Island would always hold out. Rhode Island was called Rogue Island, because everyone hated Rhode Island was always like, nah, we don't think so. It's like the tiniest little like speck of a state. And they're like, we're so big with our britches. We say no. And you don't have to do it.
所以新的马萨诸塞州宪法包含了一个修正条款。因此，当你来到1787年的费城时，记住，他们开会的原因是因为《邦联条例》，这是唯一将美国维系在一起的东西，而修改《邦联条例》的唯一方法是获得所有州的全体一致同意。但他们永远无法修改它们，因为罗德岛总是会拖后腿。罗德岛被称为流氓岛，因为每个人都讨厌罗德岛，它总是表现得像，不，我们不这么认为。它就像是一个州中最小的微尘。而他们却摆出一副我们尾大不掉的样子。我们说不。而且你们不用这么做。
We say. So the reason that they're, you know, they have to have a convention to write a new constitution is because the other thing is unamendable. So this is where a long explanation for why there exists, Article 5. It was completely non-controversial at the convention in 1787. Everyone understood this thing had to be amendable. No one was going to ratify it if it couldn't be changed. So that's where it comes from, but the provision itself is kind of a pig's breakfast. Like it's got all these compromises in it.
我们说了算。所以他们之所以必须召开会议来编写新宪法，是因为另一个东西是不可修改的。因此，这就是为什么存在第五条的长篇解释。在1787年的制宪会议上，这完全是没有争议的。每个人都明白这个东西必须是可以修改的。如果不能改变，没有人会去批准它。这就是它的由来，但这个条款本身有点像杂烩。就像里面包含了所有的妥协。
And they just sort of guessed about what might be the right bar. Like they have this Goldilocks problem, right? Like they're writing constitution. They wanted to be amendable. But they don't want it to be impossible to amend it. it needs to be amendable, but they don't have to be too easy to amend it because they don't, they want the thing to be sort of stable and, you know, get its legs before people start knocking it over. So they come up with this double super majority provision, right? The two-thirds of both houses
他们只是凭空猜测什么样的标准可能是合适的。就像他们遇到了金凤花姑娘问题一样，对吧？就像他们在编写宪法。他们希望它是可以修改的。但他们又不想让它变得不可能修改。它需要能够被修改，但又不能太容易被修改，因为他们不希望这个东西太不稳定，需要让它在人们开始推翻它之前站稳脚跟。所以他们想出了这个双重超级多数条款，对吧？国会两院的
of Congress have to pass it. Then it goes to the states and three quarters of the states have to ratify it. And I don't know, that doesn't seem crazy from the advantage of 1787, but it turns out very quickly, it's much harder to achieve that double supermajority than they anticipated. And in fact, there are two different routes, actually, right? So maybe you could talk to us about that. And which one became the de facto route? Yeah, I mean, they have, they don't, they don't give this enough attention is one thing to say. Like, remember, like, they don't even get to this question.
三分之二必须通过它。然后它提交给各州，四分之三的州必须批准它。我不知道，从1787年的角度来看，这似乎并不疯狂，但事实证明，很快，要实现这种双重超级多数比他们预期的要困难得多。事实上，实际上有两条不同的途径，对吧？所以也许你可以跟我们聊聊这个。哪一条成了事实上的途径？是的，我的意思是，他们有，他们没有，他们没有给予这方面足够的关注，这是可以这么说的一点。就像，记住，就像，当他们讨论到第五条时，他们甚至还没有真正解决这个问题。
It's, it's, they've made so many compromises and there's like so much blood on the floor by the time they get to Article 5. people are like, all right, yeah, so it's got to be amendable. But then there's like a little bit of discussion of like, well, how would that work? And so there's a few different plans. And you could sort of see they're just like, all right, whatever, put it all in there. Like, okay, so you can actually, states can petition Congress to amend the Constitution. And that's a way to introduce a possible amendment. States can also hold a convention.
当他们讨论到第五条时，他们已经做出了太多的妥协，地上有太多的血迹。人们说，好吧，是的，所以它必须是可以修改的。但随后又进行了一些讨论，比如，这到底该怎么运作？所以有几种不同的方案。你可以看出他们当时的想法基本上是，好吧，管他呢，把所有东西都塞进去。好吧，所以实际上，各州可以向国会请愿来修改宪法。这是引入潜在修正案的一种方式。各州也可以举行会议。
There can be a second constitutional constitution. convention. And if Congress passes an amendment and goes to the states for ratification, it can be ratified in a number of ways. Like the state legislature can just vote on it or the state could decide to hold a ratifying convention. And some of these things have been done and some of them have enough enough. We've never had a second constitutional convention and just failed as an idea. It didn't work. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, immediately after the Constitution is sent to the states for ratification in September of 1787.
可以举行第二次制宪会议。如果国会通过了一项修正案并提交给各州批准，它可以通过多种方式获得批准。比如州议会可以直接对它进行投票，或者一个州可以决定举行批准会议。其中一些方法已经被使用过了，而另一些方法则没有。我们从未有过第二次制宪会议，它作为一个想法失败了。它没有成功。是的。是的。我的意思是，在1787年9月宪法被提交给各州批准之后不久。
Like, imagine that there was a new Constitution and went to the states today. The first thing that would happen would be, every would be like, California would be like, well, we want this and this and this and it. And Texas would say, we know, we want this, this, and Michigan would say, like, we like it just as it is. But Minnesota would be like,
想象一下，如果现在有一部新宪法并提交给各州。首先发生的事情将是，每个人都会，加利福尼亚会说，嗯，我们想要这个、这个还有这个。德克萨斯会说，你知道的，我们要这个、这个，而密歇根会说，就像，我们喜欢它现在的样子。但明尼苏达会说，
we just have this one thing you want to add. And, you know, New York would be like, we have three things in here. So we will not sign this unless these are out. Like immediately what happened and there's only 13 states, but they all were like, uh, we have some requests. And so it was immediately a political problem of ratification was the possibility of amendment because a bunch of states said, well, like New Hampshire was like,
我们只有这唯一的一点想要添加。而且，你知道，纽约会说，我们这里有三点。所以除非这些被剔除，否则我们不会签署这个。就像立即发生的情况一样，当时只有13个州，但他们都说，呃，我们有一些要求。因此，批准过程立即成为了一个政治问题，因为存在修改的可能性，因为一群州说，嗯，比如新罕布什尔州说，
we're not even going to vote because we can't even. But Massachusetts and Maryland were like, we'll ratify it only if you promise to add these 13 amendments that we're going to officially send to you. So then all the states were like, oh, you mean we can actually add amendments? And the Federalists kept going out there with like their whole spin on the thing
我们甚至不会投票，因为我们根本不能。但马萨诸塞州和马里兰州则表示，只有你们承诺添加我们将正式提交给你们的这13条修正案，我们才会批准它。于是所有的州都说，哦，你是说我们实际上可以添加修正案？而联邦党人则不断出去宣传他们的整套说辞，
was ratify first, amend later. Like they're like, you picture the cheerleader ratify first, amen to the pom-poms. Like this is their chant. Ratify first, amend later. Like we just got to ratify the thing. But two states say we actually need a second constitutional convention
那就是先批准，后修改。就像你可以想象啦啦队拿着花球喊着先批准，修改。这就是他们的口号。先批准，后修改。就像我们必须先把这东西批准了再说。但有两个州表示，我们实际上需要第二次制宪会议，
because there have been over 200 amendments proposed in the state ratifying conventions. So finally, the federalists win the argument, and they promise. They promise, they promise, like, cross my heart and hope to die. The first thing we'll do if you guys agree to ratify this is we will amend it. In Congress, we'll hold a special session. We'll look at all the amendments that were proposed in the states and we'll send amendments back to the states. So that's the only reason we even have this constitution. because eventually the states are like, okay, that seems fine.
因为在各州的批准会议上已经提出了超过200项修正案。最后，联邦党人赢得了争论，他们做出了承诺。他们承诺，他们承诺，就像对心发誓至死不渝。如果我们这些人同意批准这个，我们要做的第一件事就是修改它。在国会将召开特别会议。我们将审查在各州提出的所有修正案，并将修正案发回各州。所以这就是我们拥有这部宪法的唯一原因。因为最终各州觉得，好吧，这似乎可以接受。
Could you talk about the nature of amending a constitution? Like, I was kind of blown away by the idea that you could, you know, you could conceive of a constitution where you just erase it and then replace it, but they decided to keep it all. And what the thinking went into all of that? Yeah. Yeah, this is weird to me. There's a great book by Jonathan Gannap that's just out this year.
你能谈谈修改宪法的性质吗？比如，我被这样一种想法深深震撼了：你可以，你知道，你可以构想这样一部宪法：你直接把它擦掉然后替换掉，但他们决定把所有内容都保留下来。这背后的思考过程是什么？是的。是的，这对我来说很奇怪。乔纳森·甘纳普今年刚出版了一本很棒的书。
And he had laid this all out, I think, in a law review article previously, but it's in his new book as well, in which it really shakes up your sense of the, I don't know, the scripture-like quality of the document. Because so by, when first Congress is held, to have an election, Washington becomes president, and they seat the first Congress. And James Madison is a member of that Congress. Madison's off the thought of the father of the Constitution because he sort of wrote the first draft. Madison had been really opposed to amending the Constitution and he had been really opposed to what the anti-federalists most wanted was a bill of rights.
他之前在一篇法律评论文章中把这些都列出来了，但它也收录在他的新书中，这确实打破了你对该文件那种神圣不可侵犯品质的认知。因为当第一届国会召开时，举行了选举，华盛顿成为总统，他们让第一届国会议员就座。詹姆斯·麦迪逊是该国会的成员。麦迪逊被称为宪法之父，因为他草拟了第一稿。麦迪逊此前一直坚决反对修改宪法，并且坚决反对反联邦党人最想要的东西，即权利法案。
This is a bad idea and he has a really solid argument about that. But he runs for the Senate. He loses the Senate cease because people are like, that guy doesn't even like amendments. And so he's like, okay, I'm now, I recognize we have to amend the thing. We promised that we would. And so it's like every day of the first session of Congress, he's like,
这是一个糟糕的主意，他对此有一个非常坚实的论点。但他竞选参议员。他竞选参议员失败了，因为人们觉得，那个家伙甚至不喜欢修正案。所以他说，好吧，现在我认识到我们必须修改这个东西。我们承诺过我们要这么做。所以就像在国会第一届会期的每一天，他都在说，
we said we'd amend it. And nobody wants to do it. They have a lot of other things to do. It's like the first Congress. They have a lot of this. But it gets to be June of 1789. And on June 8th, he gets up and he gives this speech. He's like, okay, really we have to do this now.
我们说过我们要修改它。但没有人想这么做。他们有很多其他事情要做。就像第一届国会一样。他们有很多这样的事情。但到了1789年6月。在6月8日，他站起来发表了这篇演讲。他说，好吧，我们现在真的必须这么做了。
Like, we have to do this. So he's gone through the 200-plus proposed amendments from the states, and he's whittled them down to this really interesting list of 12. and he introduces them. So then there's a lot of debate in Congress about which of these they might send to the states. And then they're add some more, they take some away. But once they decide that they're going to send them to the states, there's exactly, as you say, in this question of like, well, what would it look like to amend this document?
就像，我们必须这么做。所以他梳理了各州提出的200多项拟议修正案，并将它们精简为这份非常有趣的12项修正案清单。然后他提交了这些修正案。于是国会内部就这些修正案中哪些应该提交给各州展开了大量辩论。然后他们又增加了一些，删掉了一些。但一旦他们决定将其提交给各州，正如你所说的那样，就会出现这样一个问题：好吧，修改这份文件会是什么样子？
Because what Madison has written isn't just like in paragraph two, line four, change the to theirs. like it's not like an edit like a track changes um it's a it's a list of new things it's the first you know it's like the first amendment congress shall not congress shall not um so it's a bill of rights and in the states the bills of rights or declaration of rights appear usually at the top of the constitution but they're their own separate section so partly it looks like oh these new these amendments kind of are a set and they should maybe just appear at the end these people Ginnap calls them the supplementalists. Like they'll be supplemental to the Constitution.
因为麦迪逊写的内容不仅仅是像在第二段第四行把“the”改成“theirs”。它不像修订痕迹（track changes）那样的编辑，它是一个新事物的列表，它是第一条（你知道，就像第一修正案：国会不得……国会不得……）。所以它是一个权利法案，而在各州，权利法案或权利宣言通常出现在宪法顶部，但它们是独立的部分。所以从某种程度上看，哦，这些修正案是一套独立的组合，也许它们应该直接出现在最后？这群人，甘纳普称他们为“补充主义者”。就像他们将作为宪法的补充。
But then other people like, yeah, but they they contradict some of the stuff that's already in there. So how would you read a document that like part one says X, Y and Z and and part two says not X, Z times two, X only on Friday? Like it doesn't make any sense. Like how would people know how to read it? But then there are these practical arguments against these people. are called the incorporationists. They want to actually go back and do the track changes thing.
但其他人则认为，是的，但它们与已经写在里面的某些内容相矛盾。那你怎么去阅读这样一份文件：第一部分说X、Y和Z，第二部分却说非X、Z的两倍、仅在周五才是X？这根本说不通。人们怎么知道该如何阅读它呢？但也有针对这些人的实际反对意见。这些人被称为“整合主义者”。他们实际上想回去做类似修订痕迹（track changes）的事情。
But the supplementalists win partly because, well, we've already printed it. Like it's in books, like in school books and stuff. And like it's going to be a pain. It's like someone's telling me like changing the Department of Defense to the Department of War is going to cost like $10 billion because of the stationary. And you're like, who even has stationary anymore? But that was kind of a thing with the Constitution. So it has these huge consequences.
但补充主义者获胜，部分原因在于，好吧，我们已经把它印出来了。它印在书里，比如教科书之类的东西里面。而且这样会很麻烦。这就像有人告诉我，把国防部改名为战争部会因为信纸而花费大约100亿美元。你会想，现在谁还用信纸啊？但这确实是宪法面临的一个问题。所以它产生了巨大的后果。
Like, I don't know. You guys know, I don't remember this. But some years ago when, like, there was a lot of constitutional fetishism during the Tea Party movement, the Tea Party caucus read out loud the Constitution on the floor of Congress. And they skipped over, like, the three-fifths clause. Like, they just, like, silently removed it because, you know, it is abolished by the 13th Amendment. Right. But because the supplementalists and not the incorporationists, one, it is still in there. It's like a record of the thing.
我不知道。你们知道，我不记得这个了。但几年前，在茶党运动期间存在很多对宪法的迷恋时，茶党核心小组在国会大厅大声朗读了宪法。而他们跳过了诸如五分之三条款之类的东西。就像他们，悄悄地把它删掉了，因为，你知道的，它已经被第十三修正案废除了。没错。但由于补充主义者而不是整合主义者获胜，它仍然留在那里。它就像是那东西的记录。
It's like version control or something. But it is, it's a super odd quality of our constitution. And I guess some people think it also contributes to the veneration of the original constitution because nobody's ever like scratched it up. I mean? Like that we'd have more of a sense that it is amendable if we pictured it as something where, oh, then there was that like little squiggly line and there's like the bubble where you write in the new thing. That's right.
它就像是版本控制之类的东西。但它是的，这是我们宪法中一种超级奇怪的特质。我想有些人认为它也有助于人们对最初宪法的崇拜，因为从来没有人把它划掉。我的意思是？如果我们把它想象成那种哦，这里有一个小波浪线，然后有一个气球框让你在里面写新东西的东西，我们可能就会觉得它更有可修改性。没错。
And so the one that we have now, of course, has been amended, you know, 27 times. But I'm struck that your book is not entitled The Successful 27. It's actually a book about a lot of failures, right? And so many failures, so many interesting failures failed in it. So what can we learn from this history of things that didn't happen are not part of the official record? Yeah, so I was teaching class where I was having my students do a mock constitutional convention. I had one of them to prepare constitutional amendments all semester.
所以我们现在拥有的这部宪法，当然已经被修改了27次。但令我震惊的是，你的书不叫《成功的27次》。它实际上是一本关于很多失败的书，对吧？里面有这么多的失败，这么多有趣的失败。那么，我们能从这些没有发生、不属于官方记录的历史中学到什么呢？是的，我当时在上课，让我的学生们进行模拟制宪会议。整个学期我都让他们准备宪法修正案。
And one of their early assignments early in the semester was going to be like, look up if anyone has ever tried to do the thing that you're proposing. Part of your white paper would need to be a previous effort. So let's say you want to. you wanted to add a voting rights amendment or something. You know, you were supposed to include who and when and had ever proposed such an amendment and what had been its fate.
他们学期初的早期作业之一就是：查阅是否有人曾经尝试做过你所提议的事情。你的白皮书的一部分需要包含先前的努力。比方说你想。你想添加一项投票权修正案之类的东西。你知道，你本应包括是谁、在什么时候曾提出过这样的修正案，以及它的命运如何。
And it turned out that was really hard to do because we don't even really, we just don't have much of a sense of the failed amendments. So I ended up getting a grant from the great and now gone national down for the humanities to spend some years devising a fully searchable public archive, digital archive, of every attempt to meaningfully amend the U.S. Constitution.
事实证明，这真的很难做到，因为我们甚至没有、我们对失败的修正案实在没有什么概念。所以我最终从伟大且如今已不存在的国家人文基金会（National Endowment for the Humanities）获得了一笔资助，花了几年的时间设计了一个完全可搜索的公共档案库，一个数字档案库，收录了对美国宪法进行有意义修改的每一次尝试。
So it's thousands and thousands and thousands of amendments like some 12,000 that were introduced on the floor of Congress. And again, like, as you say, only 27 ever were ratified. So I did that mainly just for the sake of my, I thought, like more people than me would like to do this exercise as a class exercise. But it actually was really, really interesting. And in reading about other people's efforts to compile a record of the failed constitutional amendments, this one guy in like 1876, or maybe it was 1887, like this
所以这里有成千上万的修正案，比如在国会大厅提出的约12000项修正案。正如你所说，再次强调，只有27项最终得到了批准。所以我做这个主要是为了我自己的学生，我当时想，除了我之外，会有更多的人愿意把这个练习当作课堂练习。但它实际上真的非常非常有趣。在阅读其他人汇编失败宪法修正案记录的努力时，有个家伙在1876年左右，或者可能是1887年，也就是宪法编写一个世纪之后，
century after the Constitution was written, said, you know, I've been studying these things. It turns out like, is it an incredibly meaningful record of the political aspirations of the American people to look at the failed amendments? And I thought that was true. And I mean, I don't love them. of those 12,000 members are horrible ideas. But like they are a record of what people have wanted and not been able to get. And I just was like, well, maybe that would be an interesting way.
说：“你知道的，我一直在研究这些东西。结果表明，从失败的修正案来看，它原来是美国人民政治诉求的一个极其有意义的记录。”我觉得这是真的。而且我的意思是，我并不喜欢那12000个成员中的绝大多数，它们都是糟糕的主意。但它们确实记录了人们想要却未能得到的东西。我当时就在想，嗯，也许这将是一个有趣的方式。
I mean, just how I ended up writing the book. So maybe that would be an interesting way to tell the story of the Constitution. Because so much of how I think Americans think about the Constitution is there's this like, you know, the arc of the covenant, it's the scripture and the state. in the National Archives, or it's like what nine robed justices say it is. And so, like in law school, I mean, Elizabeth, you might contest this. Elizabeth, you might contest this. My experience is observing how constitutional history to the degree it's taught in law
我是说，这就是我写这本书的方式。所以也许这将是讲述宪法故事的一种有趣的方式。因为美国人对宪法的看法很大程度上是这样的：有这样一个约柜般的圣物，它是国家档案馆里的经文，或者它是九位穿着法袍的大法官所说的那样。所以，就像在法学院里——伊丽莎白，你可能会反驳这一点。伊丽莎白，你可能会反驳这一点。根据我的经验，观察法学院在多大程度上教授宪法历史，
schools, really, it's just like a bunch of Supreme Court decisions. Yes, absolutely. Like, you know, it's like on Tuesday it's dread scott and, you know, then it's Lochner and then we're at Brown v. Board. Like, that's what the constitution is. And I am as a historian, I'm like, what about the people? Like I, what? This is so weird to me.
实际上只是一堆最高法院的判决。是的，绝对如此。就像，你知道，周二是斯科特诉桑福德案，然后是洛克纳案，接着我们到了布朗诉教育委员会案。这就是宪法。而我作为一名历史学家，我会想：人民去哪儿了？我，什么？这对我来说太奇怪了。
So I really like the idea of trying to unsettle our notion of what constitutional history is by by paying attention to all the things that people have wanted the Constitution to be. And often have succeeded in some, to some degree, even without a successful form of Article 5 Amendment. So yeah, I just kind of wanted to blow that up as a way to also. Also, to remind me and my readers of two things. One, that a founding idea of our system of constitutionalism is what I call the philosophy of amendment.
所以我真的很喜欢这种想法：试图通过关注人们一直希望宪法成为的所有事物，来动摇我们对什么是宪法历史的固有观念。并且通常在某种程度上取得了成功，甚至不需要成功形式的第五条修正案。所以是的，我只是想打破这种观念，以此作为一种方式。同时，也是为了提醒我和我的读者两件事。第一，我们宪政体系的创立理念是我所谓的“修正哲学”。
The idea that the people should be making things better when it should be changing things peacefully when it's necessary to change things. Yeah. And the other is just this notion that the Constitution is actually our Constitution. Yeah. It doesn't belong to the court. When we come back, we talk about why the framers felt it was necessary to be able to change the Constitution. and how Article 5 amendments began to become functionally impossible. You write about the framers of the Constitution being, you know, acutely aware of what it would mean if the Constitution wasn't amendable.
即当有必要改变事物时，人们应该通过和平方式让事情变得更好、改变事物。是的。另一个则是这样一种观念：宪法实际上是我们自己的宪法。是的。它不属于法院。当我们回来时，我们将讨论为什么制宪先贤认为有必要能够修改宪法，以及为什么第五条修正案开始变得在功能上不可能实现。你写到宪法制定者们，你知道的，敏锐地意识到如果宪法不可修改意味着什么。
Because, you know, there wasn't a lot of precedent of longstanding constitutions and when they're not amendable. I don't know, maybe the one before this was the longest lasting was 20 years, you know, like outside. You know, like, you know, and so how did they treat the desirability of not just the necessity, but the desirability of amending the Constitution. So they talked about Parliament's behavior during the years before the American Revolution as having been unconstitutional. So England does not have a written constitution, but that doesn't bar the sons of liberty and the resistance from saying all the time, you know, when they say, you know, we oppose the Sugar Act, the Stamp Act, the Townsend Act, the T-Act, the T-Act, the Ntall, the chorus of acts, they said because they're unconstitutional. because of no taxation without representation. So they had no remedy for being faced with tyrannical, unconstitutional acts on the part of their government, except revolution.
因为，你知道的，长期存在的宪法并没有太多先例，而且当它们不可修改时……我不知道，也许在此之前历时最长的也就是20年，你知道的，大致如此。你知道的，所以他们是如何看待不只是必要性、还有修改宪法的可取性的呢？所以他们谈到美国革命前几年议会的行为是不合宪法的。因此英国没有成文宪法，但这并不妨碍自由之子和抵抗力量一直说（当他们说“我们反对《糖税》、《印花税》、《汤森法案》、《茶税》、所有这些法案”时），因为它们是不合宪法的。因为没有代议制就没有赋税。因此，面对政府暴虐的、违宪的行为，除了革命之外，他们没有任何补救办法。
And the revolutionary war is so distant in time, and we have so little sense of the kind of suffering that 18th century warfare meant. but there are types of misery that are just unfathomable to us in terms of the daily suffering of people in wartime. Modern war is more lethal, for sure. The machinery of modern war is more lethal. But people are living in such a general state of deprivation with essentially zero medical care and hardly any food to begin with.
而革命战争在时间上是如此遥远，我们对18世纪战争所意味着的那种苦难几乎没有概念。但对于战时人们日常所承受的痛苦而言，有些苦难是我们完全无法理解的。现代战争确实更具杀伤力。现代战争的机器更具杀伤力。但当时的人们生活在普遍匮乏的状态中，基本上零医疗服务，一开始几乎没有任何食物。
These are people who, by the time you get to 1787, you know, they're only a few years from the peace of Paris. they're not that far from Yorktown. Everybody has lost someone, seen the tremendous amount of suffering that that revolutionary war led to. The idea that the only way you could successfully deal with a government
这些人，到了1787年的时候，你知道的，他们距离巴黎和约只有几年时间。他们离约克敦并不远。每个人都失去过亲人，都目睹了那场革命战争带来的巨大痛苦。认为应对一个行为违宪的政府的唯一成功方法只能是血腥暴力的革命，这对他们来说是一种恐惧，一种恐怖。他们对他们所谓的“和平革命”的方法有着高度的自觉，甚至可以说是相当自我赞赏。
that was acting unconstitutionally would be by bloody violent revolution was horror, a terror to them. And they were very self-conscious and indeed quite self-congratulatory about the method of what they would have said, a peaceful revolution. Amendment was the great, the genius idea
在很多方面，修正案是美国宪法最伟大、最天才的想法。他们，你知道的，制宪先贤们一直都在这么说，因为他们发明了一种方法，使人民能够和平地改变政府的基本要素，而在以往的所有时代，唯一的途径就是暴力和暴动。因此他们说，你知道的，我们通过引入这一和平条款，防止了暴动政治降临到我们的共和国。所以这是另一个原因，我不知道，我真的可以。
of the American Constitution in many ways. They, you know, the framers themselves said this all the time because they had invented a method by which the people could peacefully change fundamental elements of their government, whereas in all previous time, the only method was violence and insurrection. And so they said, you know, we are preventing an insurrectionary politics from befalling our republic by introducing this peaceful provision. So that's another reason, like, I don't know, that I really can.
我是一个坚定的改良主义者。我绝不是革命者。我是一个改革者。我喜欢改革。就像这种想法：你可以通过说“嘿，我们这群人聚到了一起。我们对很多狗屁事情有分歧，但我们在这一点小事上达成了一致。请问我们能这么做吗？”——就像那样，我非常喜欢。
I'm such an ameliorist. I'm just not a revolutionary. I'm a reformer. I like reform. Like the idea that, like, you could just make things better by saying, hey, a bunch of us got together. We disagree about a lot of shit, but we agree about this little thing. Can we do that, please? Like that, I like that a lot.
这就是我做事的风格。嗯，但甚至连修正案程序本身，我的意思是，也许你可以谈谈你书中的这两个截然相反的极端。一个是，让我们来个修正案。一个例子就像1954年《布朗诉教育委员会案》之后不久，让我们搞个修正案，让修改宪法变得更容易。而在天平的另一端，是内战前的《科温修正案》。让我们确保保留奴隶制，并确保这一点永远、永远、永远不能再被修改。我想专业术语是“固化”（entrenchment）之类的。
That's kind of how I roll. Well, but even the amendment process itself, I mean, maybe you could talk about these two polar opposites in your book. One is, like, let's have an amendment. An example would be like right after Brown versus Board in 1954, let's have an amendment to make it easier to change the Constitution. And at the other end of the scale, you have the Corwin Amendment right before the Civil War. Let's make sure that we keep slavery and we make sure that that can never, ever be amended ever again. I think the technical term is entrenchment or something like that.
这些在我们的历史中都发生过，当时我们怀有这种焦虑。我们是应该让它变得容易得多，还是应该让它变得不可能修改？我想知道你对此有什么看法。是的。然而，这两项努力都没有成功。如果你进入修正案项目（Amendments Project），也就是我和我的学生建立的数据库。如果你按主题搜索，主题“修改”（amend）会调出一些结果，这些结果是试图对第五条进行修改的修正案，无论是让修改变得更容易还是更困难。我想说，你知道的，也许在2020年左右。
And these happen in our history where we have this anxiety. Should we make it a lot easier or should we make it impossible? I wonder what your thoughts are on that. Yeah. And yet neither those efforts has ever succeeded. If you go into the amendments project is this database that my students and I put together. And if you could search by topic and the topic amend, will pull up results that are amendments that try to make, that revise Article 5, but I mean either easier or more difficult to amend the, to amend. I would say, you know, it was maybe 2020.
国家宪法中心有三支不同的宪法学者团队，可以说是修改宪法。他们有保守派、进步派和自由派。他们提出了非常有趣的想法。但他们都修改了第五条。而且他们都让修改宪法变得更容易了，这很有趣，这是他们认识到的一个共同关切。但是的，因为第五条不再起作用了，你无法修改第五条。宪法存在多久之后人们才意识到
The National Constitution Center had three different teams of constitutional scholars, right, kind of revised Constitution. They had conservatives, progressives, and libertarians. And they were very interesting things that they came up with. But they all changed Article 5. And they all made it easier to amend the Constitution, which was interesting that that was a thing that they recognized as a shared concern. But yeah, because Article 5 doesn't work anymore, you can't revise Article 5. How soon into the Constitution existing did people?
第五条在以有意义的方式修改宪法方面基本上是行不通的？是的。你知道，我认为，权利法案嘛，好吧，人们对此很高兴。然后第十一和第十二修正案通过了。它们有点像是解决了那些显而易见的结构性问题。接着人们开始尝试做大事。
realize that Article 5 was kind of a non-starter when it came to changing the Constitution in a meaningful way. Yeah. You know, I think, so the Bill of Rights, okay, people were happy about that. Right. Then there's the 11th and 12th Amendment get in. They're just kind of like just the sort of obvious structural problems that didn't they get addressed. And then people start trying to do big things.
我认为第十二修正案是在1803年。1804年是新 England（新英格兰）的人们开始真正施压，基本上试图废除选举人团制度的第一次。是的。因为选举人团对新英格兰太不公平了。他们并不是那样，我的意思是，因为南方的蓄奴州由于五分之三条款拥有不成比例的权力。他们不会推翻五分之三条款，但他们开始尝试，比如篡改选举人团，以此来削弱五分之三条款。这不是出于废奴主义的情绪，而是出于一种“我们想要更多权力”的情绪。这很快就很清楚，这是行不通的。
I think the 12th Amendment is 1803. 1804 is the first time people in New England start really pressing, essentially to abolish the Electoral College. Yeah. Because the Electoral College is so unfair to New England. They're not that, I mean, because the slave states in the South have disproportionate power because of the free fifths clause. And they're not going to overturn the three-fifths clause, but they start trying to, like, tinker with the electoral college as a way to undermine the three-fifths clause. Not out of an abolitionist sentiment, but out of a like, we want more power sentiment. And that it's like very quickly clear that's not going to work.
但这随后导致了，是什么时候来着，1814年，举行了一次哈特福德会议，有点像是一次制宪会议。它只有新英格兰参与。新英格兰人在哈特福德聚在一起，他们说，天哪，这部宪法对我们来说真的不管用。而且由于第五条这个东西，我们无法通过任何修正案。真的行不通，我们该怎么办？他们开始威胁要脱离联邦。所以你当时就已经有这种现象了。
But that then leads to, what is it, 1814, there's a Hartford, a sort of like almost a constitutional convention. It's just only like New England. And New England gets together in Hartford. And they're like, man, this constitution is really not working for us. And we're not going to get any amendments through because this Article 5 thing. really not going to work, what are we going to do? And they start threatening to secede from the union. So you already have that.
但这随后引出了，是什么时候，1814年，有一个哈特福德会议，有点像是一场几乎是宪法的会议。它只有新英格兰地区参与。新英格兰人在哈特福德聚集在一起。他们觉得，天哪，这部宪法对我们真的很不适用。而且由于这个第五条的问题，我们根本通过不了任何修正案，真的行不通，我们该怎么办？于是他们开始威胁要脱离联邦。所以这种情况其实早就存在了。
And then the next kind of big crisis, since the 1830s, when South Carolina starts threatening secession over the tariff, there's a whole kind of by the 1830s, is it really that there's concern that the Article 5 doesn't work? It's more like it's become clear by the 1830s. that there are different understandings of what the Constitution even is. So that's when John C. Calhoun says, you know, if we don't like a law passed by Congress, we don't have to obey it.
然后是下一个重大危机，自1830年代以来，南卡罗来纳州开始因关税问题威胁要脱离联邦，1830年代左右的情况是，大家真的在担心第五条失效了吗？更像是到了1830年代，情况已经变得明朗。那就是对宪法本身究竟是什么，存在着不同的理解。所以就在那时，小约翰·卡尔霍恩说，你知道的，如果我们不喜欢国会通过的一法律，我们就不必遵守它。
Right. You can just nullify it. Because we're not really, the federal government isn't sovereign. Only the states are sovereign. And they're just like light recommendations that Congress will offer us. So like it's just a league. You're a confederacy. You're not a union, right?
对。你完全可以废止它。因为我们并不是真的，联邦政府并不是主权的拥有者。只有各州才是主权者。国会提供给我们的那些东西，不过是一些参考建议。所以它只是一个同盟。你们是一个邦联。你们不是一个联邦，对吧？
You already have that. So I'm just musing now as like over like when does. But like as a historian, it's clear that why Article 5 is kind of a dead letter before the Civil War is the only thing that really matters that people really care about constitutionally is slavery. And that cannot be addressed by Article 5. Not because the slave trade thing that is prohibited from Article 5 revision until 1808, but because there's just no way for three quarters of the states to agree on slavery. Like they barely agreed on it in 1787. Yeah.
你们已经有那种情况了。所以我现在只是在沉思，比如在思考到底是在什么时候。但作为一名历史学家，很明显，为什么第五条在内战前基本上成了一纸空文，因为人们在宪法层面真正关心的唯一重要事情就是奴隶制。而这是无法通过第五条来解决的。倒不是因为第五条禁止在1808年之前对奴隶贸易进行修改，而是因为四分之三的州根本没有办法就奴隶制达成一致。就像他们在1787年几乎勉强达成一致那样。是的。
So it's like you can't get the engine to turn over because the key, like it's all about slavery. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But what's remarkable then, of course, are the Reconstruction amendments. They happen all at once, seemingly historically, right? They happen very quickly. And that seems like a real turning point, right? And maybe you could help us understand, like, why do moments like that happen in the Article 5 story?
所以这就好比你无法让发动机运转起来，因为钥匙，一切都围绕着奴隶制。是啊，是啊，是啊。但当然，引人注目的则是重建修正案。从历史的角度来看，它们似乎是一下子全部通过的，对吧？它们的通过速度非常快。这似乎是一个真正的转折点，对吧？也许你能帮我们理解，像这样的时刻为什么会出现在第五条的故事中？
That's a big success. Yeah. So the 13th Amendment, which is 1865, the 14th Amendment is 1868, and the 15th is 1870. Those are the dates of their ratification. So what the South said at the time and what many Southern certainly southern segregation has said for decades is that in fact those are unconstitutional constitutional amendments because the south was not in congress so the 39th congress that comes up with the 14th amendment it's only the union states that are there or then there are
那是个巨大的成功。是的。因此，第十三修正案是在1865年，第十四修正案是在1868年，而第十五修正案是在1870年。这些是它们获得批准的日期。所以南方当时所说的话，以及许多南方人、当然还有南方的种族隔离主义者几十年来一直所说的是，事实上这些都是违宪的宪法修正案，因为南方当时不在国会中，所以提出第十四修正案的第39届国会，里面只有北方联邦的州，或者当时有
elected delegates, representatives from the South, but since anyone who served in the Confederate military is disqualified from holding office, like the South would say those were carpetbackers. And then in order to get back into the union and recognized as a state in the union, the former Confederate states are required to ratify the 14th Amendment. So they would say, like, yeah, well, we didn't vote for it in Congress and we ratified it like at the point of a gun. So like I should have led with, yes, the Civil War and Reconstru, the 13, 14th, 15th Amendment are amazing
从南方选出的代表、议员，但由于任何曾在南方邦联军队服役的人都被取消了担任公职的资格，南方会说那些人是外来政客（地毯贝袋客）。然后，为了重新加入联邦并被承认是联邦内的一个州，前南方邦联各州被要求批准第十四修正案。所以他们会说，没错，我们在国会里没有为它投票，我们是在枪口下批准它的。所以我本应该先说，是的，内战与重建，第13、14、15修正案太惊人了
and they reconstitute the country. And they are generally thought of by historians as essentially a second constitutional convention. Especially the 39th Congress is essentially a constitutional convention. Like that's all they're doing, is trying to figure out what should be in the 14th Amendment, which is extremely long and is, the most important amendment to the Constitution.
它们重组了国家。历史学家通常认为它们基本上是第二次制宪会议。特别是第39届国会，本质上就是一次制宪会议。他们当时所做的全部事情，就是弄清楚第十四修正案里应该写些什么，该修正案极其冗长，并且是宪法中最重要的一项修正案。
So it is a whole new beginning, a second founding, as Eric Foner calls it. That said, and so it's a miracle, but it's only accomplished because 750,000 people have just died in a civil war. And the defeated South is being treated like a conquered country and disenfranchised. It makes passing amendments easier. It makes passing amendments easier. But for you also, there's the real turning point, I guess historically in your story, is 1971. Effectively, you say Article 5 is dead in arrival in 1971.
所以这是一个全新的开始，正如埃里克·方纳所称的第二次建国。话虽如此，这是一个奇迹，但它的达成仅仅是因为有75万人在一场内战中刚刚丧生。而被击败的南方正被当成一个被征服的国家对待并被剥夺了公民权。这使得通过修正案变得更容易了。这使得通过修正案变得更容易了。但对你来说，历史上的真正转折点，我想在你的叙事中是1971年。实际上，你说第五条在1971年一出世就夭折了。
And in fact, if you go back to Law Review articles going stretching the past 50 years or so, you find titles like the Frozen Article 5, the comatose Article 5, you know, all of these crazy metaphors. So what's wrong? What happened in 1971? Yeah. So the amendments we do have really have come in bursts. Like the Bill of Rights was all at once, the Reconstruction Amendment essentially all at once.
事实上，如果你回顾过去50年左右的法学评论文章，你会发现诸如“冻结的第五条”、“昏迷的第五条”这样的标题，你知道，所有这些离奇的比喻。那么究竟出了什么问题？1971年发生了什么？是的。我们实际拥有的修正案确实是一阵一阵出现的。比如《权利法案》是一次性通过的，重建修正案基本上也是一次性通过的。
The progressive amendments are four amendments between 1913, 1920. And then there's four amendments between 1961 and 1971. And then since then, it's like a flat line. There's one blip, which is in 1992. The 27th Amendment is ratified. introduced in 1789 and was kind of lost in the paperwork. So I don't think of quiet. So why have we not amended the U.S. Constitution since 1971 then? It's one of the longer dry spells. It's not the longest. So
进步主义修正案是1913年至1920年期间通过的四项修正案。然后是1961年至1971年之间的四项修正案。在那之后，就像是一条平直的线。只有一个小插曲，那就是在1992年。第27修正案得到了批准。它是在1789年提出的，结果在文书堆里被弄丢了。所以我不认为那是平静。那么，为什么自1971年以来我们再也没有修改过美国宪法呢？这是较长的一段停滞期。它不是最长的。所以
like any social scientist would immediately raise her hand and say, well, that's because of polarization. Political polarization in the United States has been rising since 1968. And there's no sign of it, really. I mean, there's like some variability. But the double-sup majority requirements, two-thirds and three-quarters, that was devised before there were even political parties.
就像任何社会学家会立即举手说的那样，嗯，这是因为极化。美国的政治极化自1968年以来一直在加剧。而且它真的没有任何迹象。我是说，会有一些变动。但是超级多数的门槛要求，三分之二和四分之三，那是在甚至还没有政党之前就制定出来的。
So that's one reason that's become much harder than was anticipated. But now there are political parties and they're utterly polarized. So, I mean, this is a big news item and a hot take on my part, but Congress can do nothing. to that. Everybody knows Congress is useless.
所以这就是为什么它变得比预期困难得多的一个原因。但现在有了政党，而且它们完全陷入了极化。所以，我的意思是，这是一个重大新闻，也是我个人的一个犀利观点，但国会对些无能为力。
Sorry. Congress can accomplish absolutely zero. So they're really not going to get two-thirds of both houses to agree to anything, like anything, because of polarization. So you would say that. But also, what happens in 1971, is that what comes to be called originalism is born in its modern form in a famous law review article by Robert Boy. work, he is opposed to judicial activism, which when people say judicial activism, they usually mean amending from the bench, right? And so he's opposed to Griswold v. Connecticut from 1965, and then he's going to be opposed to Roe v. Wade. Like, he's opposed to the idea that there can be a right to privacy can be found in the Bill of Rights that can guarantee reproductive rights.
抱歉。国会绝对什么也做不成。所以由于极化，他们真的不可能让两院的三分之二多数同意任何事情，哪怕是任何小事。所以你会这么说。不仅如此，1971年发生的事情是，后来被称为原旨主义的东西在其现代形式下诞生于罗伯特·博克的一篇著名法学评论文章中。在他的著作中，他反对司法积极主义，当人们说司法积极主义时，他们通常是指从法官席上进行修宪，对吧？所以他反对1965年的“格里斯沃尔德诉康涅狄格州案”，然后他将反对“罗诉韦德案”。就像是，他反对在《权利法案》中可以找到一项能够保障生殖权利的隐私权的这种观点。
So he says, you know, what we need to do is go back to the original. intention of the framers of the Constitution. They didn't mean for women to be able to get birth control, so therefore it's not in the Constitution. And this theory of jurisprudence gets elaborated over the course of the 1970s, and then institutionalized in the 1980s when Reagan is president and makes originalism,
所以他说，你知道，我们需要做的是回到宪法制定者的最初意图上去。他们并不是打算让女性能够获得避孕措施，因此这并不在宪法之中。这种法理学理论在20世纪70年代逐渐得到阐述，然后在20世纪80年代里根担任总统期间被制度化，里根使原旨主义——
which at that point is called originalism, the official policy of the Reagan Justice Department, and anyone being put forward to the federal bench has to be an originalist, like has to pass a litmus test, which they say this. And partly that's because the reason originalism rises in this era is that it's not just that liberals can't amend the Constitution like the Equal Rights Amendment, which is passed by Congress in 1972, is not ratified.
当时被称为原旨主义——成为了里根司法部的官方政策，任何被推选进入联邦法院的人都必须是原旨主义者，就像必须通过一项纯洁性测试一样，他们会这么说。部分原因在于，原旨主义在这一时期兴起的原因不仅在于自由派无法修改宪法——比如国会在1972年通过的《平等权利修正案》最终未能获得批准。
So liberals are like, why are we going to bother trying to use Article 5? It's not working for us. We'll just go to the courts. But social and fiscal conservatives are also finding it difficult, impossible, to change the Constitution by Article 5 amendment. they want to pass a right to life amendment, especially after row flurry of these right to life amendments. They can't get that through Congress.
因此自由派会想，为什么我们要费心去试图利用第五条呢？它对我们不管用。我们直接去法院好了。但社会和财政保守派也发现，通过第五条修正案来修改宪法是困难的、甚至是不可能的。他们想要通过一项生命权修正案，特别是在“罗诉韦德案”引发的一阵生命权修正案浪潮之后。他们无法让其在国会通过。
And they want to pass a balanced budget amendment, which they can get through the Senate, but not through the House. So the fiscal concert is. So they come up with this idea, which is, well, we want to change the Constitution, but we've been saying for years, we don't believe in judicial activism. And we posed to the Warren Court.
他们想要通过一项平衡预算修正案，这个他们能在参议院通过，却无法在众议院通过。所以财政保守派们。于是他们想出了这样一个主意，那就是，好吧，我们想要修改宪法，但我们多年来一直声称，我们不相信司法积极主义。我们反对沃伦法院。
Everything in the Warren Court's done really since Brown, like all the, really the decisions of the 1960s, the civil rights decisions of the 1960s, and the criminal defendant's rights. So we want to gain power, and we want to gain seats on the federal bench, but then we don't want to do what they did because we've been saying that's not allowed.
沃伦法院所做的一切，实际上自“布朗案”以来，所有的决定，尤其是20世纪60年代的民权裁决以及刑事被告人的权利。所以我们要获得权力，我们想要在联邦法院获得席位，但随后我们又不想做他们做过的事情，因为我们一直说那是不被允许的。
And we can't be that hypocritical. So they're like, okay, well, what we're going to do actually from the bench is return to the original meaning, original understanding of the Constitution. And it's that logic that gets you to, that's how ultimately they overturn Roe v. Wade with the Dobbs decision in 2022
而且我们不能那么虚伪。所以他们在想，好吧，那么我们实际上将在法官席上做的是回到宪法的最初含义、最初理解。正是这种逻辑让你走向了那个方向，这也就是他们最终在2022年的“多布斯案”裁决中推翻“罗诉韦德案”的方式
by saying, you know, the right to privacy is not in the Constitution. We can't amend from the bench. That's wrong. But what we'll do is we'll return our interpretation to the original meaning of the Constitution. So it's a way of exercising a tremendous amount of judicial power in the guise of not constitutional change, but constitutional restoration.
通过声称，你知道，隐私权并不在宪法中。我们不能从法官席上进行修宪。那是错误的。但我们要做的，是将我们的解释回归到宪法的最初含义。因此，这是一种以不属于宪法变革、而是属于宪法恢复的名义，来行使巨大司法权力的手段。
And modesty, actually, right? I mean, the premise is, you know, we're not doing very much, although it can be quite radical. You know, one of the, you've talked about Dobbs, but just to be clear, originalism is everywhere. You know, so for instance, there's a case from 2012 where the Supreme Court, in a Scalia opinion, or ask the question, when the police, who didn't exist in the 18th century, used GPS, which clearly didn't exist in the 18th century, is that a search under the Fourth Amendment? And Scalia says, well, we need to figure out whether that would have been a search in the 18th century. And it's an absurd premise, right, the idea that you'd ask that very question.
实际上还有谦抑，对吧？我的意思是，其前提是，你知道，我们并没有做太多事情，尽管它可能会相当激进。你知道，其中一个，你谈到了“多布斯案”，但为了明确起见，原旨主义无处不在。你知道，举个例子，2012年有一个案件，最高法院在斯卡利亚的一份意见书中，提出了这样一个问题：当18世纪并不存在的警察使用在18世纪显然也不存在的GPS时，这算不算《第四修正案》所指的搜查？斯卡利亚说，我们需要弄清楚这在18世纪算不算搜查。这是一个荒谬的前提，对吧，竟然会去问这样一个问题。
Yeah, yeah, it's really kooky. And, like, the more you look at it, just, like, flat, like, look at it, look at it. You're like, it's just such a rank nonsense. But it also isn't original. It's not how anyone interpreted the Constitution when the Constitution was first put into effect. So it's odd. But it is in tension with, again,
对，对，这真的很古怪。而且，你越是去审视它，只是，比如，直面它，仔细看看它。你会觉得，这简直就是彻头彻尾的无稽之谈。但它也并非原汁原味。当宪法最初付诸实施时，根本没有人是这样去解释宪法的。所以这很奇怪。但它确实与——
what I call the philosophy of amendment. Right. If the point of the Constitution is, a point of the Constitution is going to provide stability and transparency and accountability, but it can also be changed through this peaceful means, the idea that the obligatory, of the Supreme Court is to keep turning back the clock, keep undoing change is,
我称之为修正哲学的东西存在着紧张关系。对吧。如果宪法的意义在于，宪法的意义在于提供稳定、透明和问责，但它也可以通过这种和平的方式进行改变，那么认为最高法院的职责就是不断倒拨时钟、不断撤销变革的这种想法——
seems to me to contradict the original constitution. So I have to ask you, as talking to a Harvard history professor, when you read the history done by the originalists on the Supreme Court, you know, how do you grade them? I mean, I think I try to say, like, think about originalism, like I think very smart people are originalists and they're very smart, very principled people, and I respect them, and I take for granted the good faith with which they undertake their work. I'm unpersuaded by it as a means of jurisprudence. I am entirely certain it is not original, and I would also state with some authority
在我看来，是与最初的宪法相矛盾的。所以我不得不问你，作为一名哈佛大学的历史系教授，当你阅读最高法院原旨主义者所做的历史研究时，你知道，你给他们打几分？我的意思是，我想我会试着去说，比如，看待原旨主义，我认为非常聪明的人会是原旨主义者，他们非常聪明、非常坚守原则，我尊重他们，并且我默认他们开展工作时怀有善意。作为一种法理学手段，我并不为其所说服。我绝对确信它并非原本的含义，我也带有一定权威性地指出——
that neither is it history. It really has very little to do with history, because the methods that judges use when they write originalist opinions are the methods of the law. It's not like, oh, what can be known about this in the world? It's like the sources that originals will use to determine the original meaning of the Constitution or its intention or whatever. You know, the Constitution itself, the text,
它也不是历史。它实际上与历史没有什么关系，因为法官在撰写原旨主义意见时所使用的方法是法律的方法。这不像，哦，关于这个世界可以了解些什么？它就像原旨主义者用来确定宪法最初含义或其意图等的那些来源。你知道，宪法本身、文本、
the records of ratifying convention, James Madison's notes on the Constitutional Convention, and the Federalist Papers, and like maybe a dictionary. But from the point of view, of a historian, like, you couldn't, you would never artificially bound your source material. If I were interested, if I had a historical question about, if I wanted to understand, you know, the Biden years as a historian, like, and I said, well, I'm going to actually look at the White House visitors logs and the text of Biden's press conferences. And then Jill Biden wrote a diary.
批准会议的记录、詹姆斯·麦迪逊关于制宪会议的笔记、《联邦党人文集》，以及可能还有一本字典。但从历史学家的角度来看，你绝不会人为地限制你的源材料。如果我感兴趣，如果我有一个关于历史的问题，如果我想作为一名历史学家去理解，你知道，拜登执政的岁月，然后我说，好吧，我实际上要去看白宫访客日志和拜登新闻发布会的文本。然后吉尔·拜登写了一篇日记。
And that's all I'm going to look at. like you'd learn a lot about the Biden White House with those three sources but it would be just bizarreo world like that's you know that's a D like what like if you if you want to understand the Biden White House
而这也就是我要看的一切。就像你会通过这三个来源对拜登白宫了解很多，但这将是一个光怪陆离的世界，你知道，那是一个D级作业，如果你想了解拜登的白宫
or the Biden presidency there's just that's just not how you would go about it and and maybe that's unfair and like the sources that original shoes are the very definitive sources about what the people who were in Philadelphia in 1787 may have thought. But since the whole premise of the Constitution
或者拜登总统任期，那根本就不是你该采取的方法，也许这并不公平，原旨主义者所使用的来源确实是关于1787年在费城的人们可能怎么想的最具决定性的来源。但既然宪法的整个前提
was that it is the spirit of the people, you surely, like, when I try to tell the story of Philadelphia in 1787, you're interested in what they would have called the time the people out of doors. All the people who are basically knocking on the windows and banging
是它代表着人民的精神，你当然会——当我试图讲述1787年费城的故事时，你会对他们当时所称的“门外的人”感兴趣。所有那些基本上在敲击窗户、敲击
on the doors with their ideas about what should be in the Constitution. There's just like a whole big world out there. So that's why I would say, like, I can respect it but be unpersuaded by it as a way of interpreting the Constitution. But I will never concede that it is anything to do with how history works as a form of humanistic inquiry. There's a thing about originalism that it's a thread in your book that you can, it's this creeping threat that that grows. It's not just starting in the 70s. Like there's the sort of, I sort of, the big bang of it to me is the Dolly Madison.
大门的人，带着他们关于宪法中应该包含什么的想法。外面还有一个非常广阔的世界。所以这就是为什么我要说，我虽然可以尊重它，但作为一种解释宪法的方式，我并不为其所说服。但我永远不会承认它与历史作为一种人文探究形式的运作方式有任何关系。关于原旨主义，有一点它是你书中的一条线索，你可以看到，这是一种不断蔓延且在增长的威胁。它不只是始于70年代。就像有一种，我所认为它的“大爆炸”是多莉·麦迪逊
publishing the Madison papers or something, well, all of a sudden you have to like pay attention to what they were thinking and not really think about it being an amendable living document, but like, oh, we're going back. And that's 50 years after the fact. Yeah. Yeah. I'm interested in that as the creeping force of originalism as under different names as it sort of goes through American history. Yeah. There are some moments that really blew my mind and trying to trace that. Because in a way, the book is a history of originalism. It's a history of amendments, but it's also a genealogy of originalist thought. There's a moment in the oral arguments at Brown v. Board in 1953 or 54, it was argued twice, where this guy arguing for keeping schools segregated,
出版了麦迪逊文稿之类的事情，好吧，突然之间你不得不去关注他们的想法，而不是真正去思考它是一份可以修正的活的宪法，而是像，哦，我们要回溯过去。那是事后50年的事了。对。对。我对这一点很感兴趣，作为原旨主义在通过美国历史发展时以不同名字展现的蔓延力量。对。有些时刻真的让我大开眼界，并试图去追溯这一点。因为从某种意义上说，这本书就是原旨主义的历史。它是修正案的历史，但它也是原旨主义思想的谱系。在1953年或1954年的“布朗诉托皮卡教育局案”的口头辩论中，这个案件辩论了两次，有这样一个时刻：那个为保持学校种族隔离辩护的家伙，
quotes at length, Tani's decision in Dred Scott about how the framers really, we need to always be deferring to the original intent of the framers, and they could never possibly imagine that blacks could be citizens. And you're like, I mean, it is a century after Dred Scott. And there was a war over that one. I mean, it's like, know your audience. Like, it's surprising that, like, because Dred Scott is, we could call it an originalist opinion, right? It's like, that's what the research that Tony, the Chief Justice Roger Toney offers is to prove that the framers would never have intended for.
长篇大论地引用了托尼在“斯科特诉桑福德案”中的裁决，内容关于制宪者确实——我们需要始终遵从制宪者的最初意图，而他们绝对不可能想象黑人能够成为公民。你会觉得，我的意思是，这已经是“斯科特诉桑福德案”的一个世纪之后了。而且为那个案子还打过一场仗。我的意思是，这就像是，了解你的听众。就像，这令人惊讶，因为“斯科特诉桑福德案”，我们可以称之为一份原旨主义的意见，对吧？就像，那是最高法院首席大法官罗杰·托尼提供的研究，旨在证明根据他对历史的解读，制宪者绝不会打算让黑人成为公民。
blacks to be citizens based on his reading of history. And that's the originalist argument of Brown v. Born, if you declare like modern originalists are not like defending, you know, the segregation. It's not the project of originalism. But that is the
这就是“布朗案”的原旨主义论点，如果你宣称——比如现代原旨主义者并非在为种族隔离辩护。那不是原旨主义的项目。但那确实是
is an originalist like, oh, the framers of the 14th Amendment never intended. They would never have imagined that black and white children would go to school together. That's not what they were doing in the 14th Amendment. And there's that, you know, when Chief Justice Earl Warren issues his opinion in Brown v. Board, he says, the history is inconclusive, which is his way of the thing. And the history is murky, but his thing is like, just a way to say, like, the history doesn't matter. If we were to constantly defer to the history and tradition of this country, we as a court could only ever reinstantiate racial divisions. We could never free the people from them.
一个原旨主义者的观点，比如，哦，第十四修正案的制宪者从来没有这个意图。他们绝不会想象黑人和白人儿童会一起去上学。他们在第十四修正案中可不是在做那个。而且有那么一次，你知道，当首席大法官厄尔·沃伦在“布朗案”中发布他的意见时，他说，历史是无定论的，这是他的一种表达方式。历史是模糊不清的，但他的看法就像是，这只是一种说法，意思是历史并不重要。如果我们不断地顺从这个国家的历史和传统，我们作为法院将永远只能重现种族隔离。我们永远无法把人们从其中解放出来。
And so he just, like, let's start again. And that's this guy, I've never seen him really written about by legal scholars, but his name is David J. Mays, who was a Virginia lawyer and quite talented historian. When the Pulitzer Prize in 1953 for a biography of Edmund Pendleton, who was an 18th century Virginian, Mays actually does the historical research for the segregation side of the argument in Brown v. Board of Education. And he's really pissed off when Earl Warren says, the history is inconclusive. Because Mays is like, no, it's not. I did the history. The history says the framers of the 14th Amendment did not intend for black and white children to go to school together.
所以他干脆说，让我们重新开始吧。这个家伙，我从来没见过法学学者真正写过他，他的名字叫大卫·J·梅斯，他是一名弗吉尼亚州的律师，也是一位相当出色的历史学家。凭借对18世纪弗吉尼亚人埃德蒙·彭德尔顿的传记，他在1953年获得了普利策奖，梅斯实际上为“布朗诉教育局案”中支持种族隔离的一方做了历史研究。当厄尔·沃伦说“历史是无定论的”时，他真的气坏了。因为梅斯觉得，不，并非如此。我做了历史研究。历史表明，第十四修正案的制宪者并不打算让黑人和白人儿童一起上学。
They did not intend to be banning segregated schools. And so he dedicated, he's the art. architect of what is called massive resistance in the South, which is just refusing to enact desegregation. In addition to being the architect of massive resistance, he starts writing about what he describes as the question of intent and insisting that the only way to understand the Constitution is to defer to the original intent of the framers of any constitutional provision. And he testifies before Congress on this point. And he, he, really elaborates these ideas that get picked up in the late 60s by Robert Bork.
他们并不打算禁止实行种族隔离的学校。所以他致力于——他是南方所谓的“大规模抵抗”的建筑师，而这仅仅是拒绝实施取消种族隔离政策。除了作为大规模抵抗的建筑师之外，他开始撰写关于他所描述的“意图问题”的文章，并坚称理解宪法的唯一方法就是顺从任何宪法条款制宪者的最初意图。他在国会就这一点作证。而且他，他确实详细阐述了这些理念，这些理念在60年代末被罗伯特·博克采纳了。
So he is kind of a missing link between the Brown case and what becomes the Borkian argument in 1971. And again, like not to say originalism is, you know, a rejection of the Brown decision. It is very frequently in conflict with the reasoning behind the Brown decision, right, which was history doesn't matter. We need to do the right thing, right? But this maze guy, one of the reasons he's so interesting, and I wish that people would spend a little more time being attention to him, is he left this elaborate diary that any other person would probably either have destroyed or their descendants would have destroyed. But he was like a board member of the Virginia Museum of History. He left his diary to the museum. Like his diary begins when he's a young person with, he goes to a lynching in the 19 teens and he writes about how exciting it was.
所以他可以说是“布朗案”与1971年成为博克式论点之间的“失落的环节”。再次说明，并不是说原旨主义是对“布朗案”裁决的拒绝。它非常经常与“布朗案”背后的推理相冲突，对吧，那个推理就是历史并不重要。我们需要做正确的事情，对吧？但这个叫梅斯的家伙，他之所以如此有趣、且我希望人们能花更多一点时间去关注他的原因之一，在于他留下了这本详尽的日记，换作任何其他人，可能要么自己销毁了，要么他们的后代也会将其销毁。但他曾是弗吉尼亚历史博物馆的董事会成员。他把自己的日记留给了博物馆。比如他的日记记录了他年轻时的经历，他在1910年代去观看了一场林奇（私刑），并写下了那是多么令人兴奋。
Then he goes to, he takes a train to D.C. specifically so he can see birth of a nation. Like, he is that guy. And then you see him in the 50s, like arguing for segregation. And then he writes the intellectual justification for originalism in the 60s. And it's kind of all spelled out in the diary, which has been printed. Because just really recently, within the last 10 years, someone, a great scholar edited and printed, had printed the diary. And it's, you know, it's the autobiography of segregation. Hmm.
然后他去，他专门坐火车去华盛顿特区，只为了能看到《一个国家的诞生》。他就是那种人。然后你在50年代看到他，在为种族隔离辩驳。接着他在60年代为原旨主义写下了知识上的正当性。这一切都在日记中拼凑了出来，并且已经被印刷出版了。因为就在最近，在过去10年内，某位杰出的学者编辑并印刷了这本日记。而且，你知道，这就是种族隔离的自传。嗯。
Wow. You know, part of this is, you underscores the extreme importance today of the Supreme Court, right? Because if Article 5 is effectively dead, then everybody turns to the court. But I think the consequence of your story is that we have this. aggrandizement of the Supreme Court. Like, that's the only place we turn to. And the modern court has kind of almost become like this monarchical power, right? Many of our amendments were responses to Supreme Court cases.
哇。你知道，部分原因在于，这凸显了今天最高法院的极端重要性，对吧？因为如果第五条实际上已经失效了，那么每个人都转向了法院。但我认为你的故事所带来的后果是，我们迎来了最高法院权力的膨胀。就像，那是我们唯一求助的地方。而现代法院几乎已经变成了这种具有君王般权力的机构，对吧？我们的许多修正案都是对最高法院案件的回应。
But there's no real check, of course, on the court, effective check on the court today. Yeah. And of course, in our era, it's liberals who made the Supreme Court that monarchical power, right? So sadly, there's not a lot of intellectual consistency among political actors in this story, right? Like when the court is conservative, as it was in the progressive era, progressives are all about amendment and attacking the court and bemoaning judicial supremacy or labeling it that and bemoaning it. And then for the middle decades of the 20th century, when the court is liberal, conservatives are really mad about judicial activism and judicial supremacy. But then once conservatives get control of the court again, no, then they're pretty happy with the court having all this power. And then now liberals are upset with the court having the power.
但当然，对法院没有真正的制约，今天对法院没有有效的制约。是的。当然，在我们的时代，正是自由派将最高法院塑造成了那种君王般的权力机构，对吧？所以可悲的是，在这段故事中，政治行为者之间并没有多少思想上的一致性，对吧？比如当法院是保守的时候，就像在进步时代那样，进步派全力推动修正案、攻击法院、哀叹司法最高权力或者给它贴上标签并加以哀叹。然后到了20世纪的中期几十年，当法院是自由派的时候，保守派对司法积极主义和司法最高权力感到非常愤怒。但一旦保守派重新控制了法院，不，那么他们对于法院拥有这一切权力就感到挺高兴了。而现在，自由派对法院拥有权力感到不满。
Like, it's important to just note that like there's no one who escapes that trap. We have to take a break when we come back, the story of the last successful champion of Article 5 amendments. I mean, mostly what you describe is the history of amendments not passing. you kind of, I don't know, Amendment heroes in your story who like get a bunch of stuff done. And I was particularly sort of enchanted by Senator Birch Pye, who's the last kind of amendment warrior that existed before the nail in the coffin of Article 5. Could you describe Birch Pye and his mission in life? Yeah, I love this guy. Like I am an archive rat.
就像，重要的是要注意到，没有人能逃脱那个陷阱。我们得休息一下，回来后，将讲述第五条修正案最后一位成功捍卫者的故事。我的意思是，你所描述的大多是修正案未能通过的历史。你有点，我不知道，你的故事里有修正案英雄，他们促成了一堆事情。我特别被参议员伯奇·贝伊迷住了，他是第五条棺木钉上最后一颗钉子之前存在的最后一位修正案斗士。你能描述一下伯奇·贝伊和他的人生使命吗？是的，我很喜欢这家伙。就像我是一只档案老鼠。
The historians are in two varieties. There's archive rats. and then there's like people who make sweeping generalizations. I work really hard to say something sweeping, but like I just could spend so much time with Birchby. So he's this guy from Indiana, a Democrat, very, very handsome, charming. He's kind of like the Kennedy of the Midwest.
历史学家分两种。有一种是档案老鼠，
And people thought he was like going to be a presidential contender. And in fact, he sought the Democratic nomination, I think, in 68, briefly. But he does have a law degree. And so when he gets to Senate as a young senator, Jim Eastland, who the big Mississippi segregationist, who's chair of the Senate Judiciary Committee, puts him on this graveyard committee, which is the Senate Judiciary Committee's subcommittee
另一种是那种做出宏大概括的人。我很努力地想做出一些宏大的概括，但我就是能花那么多时间去研究伯奇·贝伊。所以他是来自印第安纳州的这个家伙，民主党人，非常非常英俊，有魅力。他有点像是中西部的肯尼迪。
on constitutional amendments. And it's like where ideas go to die. You have an idea for an amendment, and it goes to that committee, and nothing's ever going to come out of that committee. But he's a very ambitious guy, though, so he's like, I don't know, maybe we should hold some hearings on some stuff.
人们认为他将成为总统候选人。事实上，我想他在68年曾短暂竞选过民主党提名。但他确实拥有法学学位。所以当他作为一名年轻参议员进入参议院时，吉姆·伊斯兰——那个来自密西西比州的大种族隔离主义者、参议院司法委员会主席——把他安排在这个被称为“墓地委员会”的机构，也就是参议院司法委员会的
And Aisland's like, dude, do not hold hearings on these things. It'll kill you. The things people want to do with constitutional amendments are like, nobody's going to win. No one's going to look good. It's going to be bad. But he starts holding hearings on things. He's like, busing, I'll hold a hearing. Abortion, let's hold a hearing.
宪法修正案小组委员会。那就是各种想法去死的地方。你有一个关于修正案的想法，它就会送到那个委员会，而那个委员会永远不会产出任何东西。但他是个很有野心的人，所以他在想，不知道，也许我们应该就某些事情举行一些听证会。
I mean, that's a little bit later. But he basically gets through four constitutional amendments in that decade. And he also is significantly responsible for getting the Equal Rights Amendment out to the states. And it's, so he would say, he would have said one of his great accomplishments was the 25th Amendment, which makes provisions for presidential disability, right? So Eisenhower had like two heart attacks and then also a surgery. Then Kennedy was shot. People were like, what do we do?
而伊斯兰说，老兄，千万别就这些事情举行听证会。这会害了你。人们想要通过宪法修正案去做的那些事情，简直没人能赢。没人能落得好。那会很糟糕。但他开始就一些事情举行听证会。他说，校车运送，我要举行听证会。堕胎，让我们举行听证会。
You know, what if Johnson had also been shot in Texas or in Dallas that day in November of 1863? So the 25th Amendment makes, is sort of succession president. succession and provisions for if a president becomes incapable of executing the office. But he also gets through, you know, the 26th Amendment, which reduces the voting age from 21 to 18, right? The student anti-war movement had really fought for that. His, he was not a big fan of the ERA, but his wife was. And she kicks him in the pants and he gets that done. But the thing he really cared about the most and is the heartbreaker.
我的意思是，那是稍微晚一点的时候。但他基本上在那十年里推动通过了四项宪法修正案。而且他还显著地负责将《平等权利修正案》推向各州。所以，他会说，他会说他伟大的成就之一是第25修正案，它对总统无行为能力做出了规定，对吧？所以艾森豪威尔曾有过两次心脏病发作，然后还做过一次手术。接着肯尼迪被枪杀。人们在想，我们该怎么办？
of, I mean, in my mind, of the book, is the abolition of the electoral college. So there had been a lot of concern about the electoral college. It's like probably the most common, most frequently introduced amendment on the floor of Congress is either to reform or abolish the electoral college. Because given changing population, it's a ticking time bomb, especially with a polarized electorate, it's a ticking time bomb. Like before, you know, 2000, it was not common. for someone to win the popular vote and lose the election.
你知道，如果在1863年11月的那天，约翰逊也在德克萨斯州或达拉斯被枪杀呢？所以第25修正案确立了，可以说是总统职位继承，以及如果一位总统失去执行该职位的权力时的各项规定。但他还推动通过了，你知道，第26修正案，将投票年龄从21岁降至18岁，对吧？学生反战运动确实为之奋斗过。他的，他不是《平等权利修正案》的超级粉丝，但他妻子是。而他妻子踢了他的屁股，于是他就把那事给办成了。但他真正最关心、并且是最让人心碎的——
Right. But that has happened several times in the 21st century. And it happened or seemed like it was about to happen. In By's era, people really worried about that because they thought that, I think rightly, it's really hard to even understand what the hell the electoral colleges and why we haven't. And so the Democratic legitimacy of a president elected who has lost the popular vote, that's tough people to take. It just is. People are uncomfortable with it. And so there were a bunch of plans, different like reforms that would make that less likely. And then there was just like, let's just
在我看来，在书中——是废除选举人团制度。所以当时有很多关于选举人团的担忧。这可能是在国会大厅中最常见、最频繁提出的修正案，不是为了改革就是为了废除选举人团制度。因为鉴于人口的变化，它是一个定时炸弹，特别是对于一个极化的选民群体来说，它是一个定时炸弹。在你知道的2000年之前，这种情况并不常见。
get rid of it. And by thought this was the natural successor to the 25th Amendment, that, which was also about presidential succession and the legitimacy of whoever's holding the old oval office. That, okay, so here's another problem of presidential succession, which is electoral college and the likelihood of someone winning the White House who did not win the majority of the votes. So he, I'm sorry, I realize my answer has become like tails. No, I want them to be tails. So this is great. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
即某人赢得普选却输掉了选举。
He thinks he's got this in the bag because he gets like, he does a survey of like every political scientist in the country, they all approve it. Americans in public opinion polls, it's like way above 80% approved abolishing the electoral College. It passes the House. It's going to go to the Senate. It's 1969. And really, the only people, weirdly, who oppose the reform is the NAACP. The NAACP has thought since the 1950s, before the Voting Rights Act, that the Electoral College was like one of the few things that amplified the black vote in the north. So blacks can't vote in the South, because of Jim Crow, but in the north they can vote. And in the cities where they have large numbers,
对。但这在21世纪已经发生好几次了。而且在贝伊的时代，它曾经发生过，或者看起来就要发生了。人们对此非常担心，因为他们认为，我认为是对的，甚至很难搞清楚选举人团到底是个什么鬼东西以及为什么我们还没废除它。因此，当选总统在输掉普选票的情况下仍能获得民主合法性，这对人们来说是很难接受的。事实就是如此。人们对此感到不舒服。所以当时有一堆计划，各种不同的改革方案，可以降低这种可能性。然后还有一种就是，让我们直接
their votes are amplified by the electoral cards. That was the thinking. And so they construed, NACP as an organization, construed any attempt to tinker with the electoral college as a way to disenfranchise black voters. So they hadn't really like updated their thinking after the Voting Rights Act, and they still thought that. And Bai kept saying, no, no, this actually is the right thing.
把它废除掉吧。贝伊认为这是第25修正案的自然继承者，第25修正案也是关于总统继承以及任何占据椭圆形办公室的人的合法性的。那好吧，这里还有另一个总统继承的问题，那就是选举人团，以及赢得白宫的人却没有赢得多数选票的可能性。所以他——对不起，我意识到我的回答变得像——没关系，我希望它们像。所以这很棒。对，对，对。
It's the right thing for civil rights. But when he introduced that, the NAACP sent a telegram to every member of the Senate, like urgently begging them to vote against the abolition of the Electoral College Amendment. So there was that problem, and he tried really hard to deal with that without much success. Because a lot of, like the Urban League, a lot of civil rights organizations agreed with by. But the problem was, they alone would not have been able to defeat the amendment. The problem was that Richard Nixon had nominated in quick succession to Southern segregationists, to seats on the Supreme Court.
他认为这已经是囊中之物了，因为他得到了——他做了一项调查，针对国内的每一位政治学家，他们都表示赞同。美国人在民意调查中，支持废除选举人团的比例远超80%。它在众议院通过了。它将送往参议院。那是1969年。而且奇怪的是，真正反对这项改革的仅有的群体是全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）。全国有色人种协进会自20世纪50年代（在《投票权法案》通过之前）起就认为，选举人团是为数不多的能够放大北方黑人选票的力量之一。因此黑人在南方无法投票，因为吉姆·克劳法，但在北方他们可以投票。在他们人数众多的城市里，
And the Democrats wanted both of them axed. And they're very, like, by would not have seemed like the person who should be wielding the axe, but like some of the guy was a coward, and then Teddy Kenny didn't want to do it because he thought he was going to run for president. I don't know, whatever.
他们的选票通过选举人团得到了放大。当时的思路就是这样的。因此，作为组织的全国有色人种协进会，将任何试图篡改选举人团的尝试都解读为剥夺黑人选民投票权的一种方式。所以他们在《投票权法案》通过后并没有真正更新他们的思维，他们仍然是那样想的。贝伊一直在说，不，不，这实际上是正确的事。
They wouldn't do it. So they're like, Birch, could you please defeat these? And so he had to go dig up the dirt and destroy the reputations of these two men, one of them really was contemptible. But the other one was really. not contemptible. And Nixon, Nixon, well, he was a problem with Nixon, but all the Southern segregationists in Congress were like, we're never doing anything for that damn guy again. And so
这对民权运动来说是正确的事。但当他提出这一点时，全国有色人种协进会向参议院的每一位成员发送了一份电报，紧急恳求他们投票反对废除选举人团修正案。所以存在着那个问题，他非常努力地去处理这个问题，但没有取得太大成功。因为许多——比如城市联盟，许多民权组织都同意贝伊的看法。但问题是，仅凭他们自己是无法击败这项修正案的。问题在于，理查德·尼克松相继提名了两位南方的种族隔离主义者进入最高法院。
they refused, they voted against abolishing the Electoral College to punish Birchby for having defeated the nominations of two of Nixon's Supreme Court justices. And that is why we still have an electoral college. That's the only reason. I mean, it's so depressing. tip for tap political rather than big ideas. Yeah. And there's a sense that he spent all of his political capital doing this and there's going to be no one else. I mean, maybe there's going to be someone else like him, but that is a depressing
而民主党人希望这两个人都被炒鱿鱼。而且他们非常——贝伊本不应该是一个挥舞斧头的人，但某些家伙是个懦夫，然后泰迪·肯尼迪不想这么做，因为他觉得自己要竞选总统。我不知道，不管怎样。
notion that it basically is a place that you kill your political career is in amendments. Yeah. Yeah. It's there's like a coda to it too. He, in the 70s, he tries again. and I think it's like 1777 and it's so stressful
他们就是不肯做。所以他们在想，伯奇，你能不能请你击败这些提名？所以他不得不去挖掘黑材料并摧毁这两个人的声誉，其中一个确实十分可鄙。但另一个真的
there's this quite brilliant conservative constitutional scholar his name's Martin Diamond who was really opposed to abolishing Electoral College and he comes to testify and buys committee and then he goes to sit and watch where the other people
并不可鄙。尼克松，尼克松，好吧，尼克松是个问题，但国会中所有的南方种族隔离主义者都觉得，我们再也不会为那个该死的家伙做任何事了。所以
who are testifying he's opposed to abolishing it but the other people who are testifying we're going to testify that day about why it's the right thing to do but the Martin Diamond has been so stressed out by his testimony he has a heart attack in the hearing room and Birchby and Orrin Hatch try to revive him and the phone, like the emergency phone in the room doesn't work
他们拒绝了，他们投票反对废除选举人团，以此来惩罚伯奇·贝伊击败了尼克松的两名最高法院大法官提名。这就是为什么我们今天仍然保留着选举人团。这就是唯一的理由。我的意思是，这太让人沮丧了。这是针锋相对的政治博弈，而不是宏大的理念。是的。而且有一种感觉，他为了做这件事耗尽了自己所有的政治资本，而且不会再有其他人了。我的意思是，也许还会有像他那样的人，但这是一种令人沮丧的
and help does not come and a guy dies and I think the hearings just never resume like it's just it was not going to happen somehow it just feels like fate is not on the side of abolishing the election which is horrible death for this poor man but it's it's I don't know It's sort of like the narrative gods are speaking as well. Yeah, yeah.
观点，即参与修正案基本上是一个会葬送你政治生涯的地方。是的。是的。这后面其实还有一个尾声。他在70年代又尝试了一次，我想大概是1777年，过程压力极大，
I find this when I read history books of things I actually know the outcome of, and I still get to that point where I'm just like, just don't go to the theater. Just don't go. And you have these moments in your book that are like that, that are just like, they just hurt your heart in a way because you think, oh, it could be so different, you know, just for these little tiny things.
当时有一位相当杰出的保守派宪法学者，他的名字叫马丁·戴蒙德，他非常反对废除选举人团，他来贝伊的委员会作证，然后他坐下来观看其他人——
Yeah, yeah. So even though there is this sort of one-way ratchet of the Article 5 that, as you discussed in your book, and racialism is on the rise and amendments become less and less possible, you do kind of end on an optimistic note about a sleeping giant that might awaken. And how do you maybe see amendment happening in the future and why might you be optimistic about such things? Partly I feel this is a strange confession to make. I feel a public duty to perform hope. So I do all the time, and whether I have it or not, maybe that's a misplaced sense of duty. I do think, though, that we are in a moment in American history of tremendous constitutional change. Tremendous constitutional change.
对，对。所以，尽管正如你在书中所讨论的那样，第五条存在这种单向的棘轮效应，种族主义也在抬头，而且修正案越来越不可能通过，但你最终还是带着一种乐观的语气，谈到一个可能会觉醒的沉睡巨人。你觉得未来可能会如何实现修宪？为什么你会对这种事情保持乐观？部分原因我觉得这是一个很难启齿的坦白。我觉得自己有履行希望的公众责任。所以我一直在这么做，不管我心里有没有这种希望，也许这是一种错位的责任感。不过，我确实认为，我们正处于美国历史上发生巨大宪法变革的时期。巨大的宪法变革。
The powers of the executive have changed dramatically in, you know, the last 10 years. The separation of powers has almost entirely eroded, not entirely, but significantly eroded. There's a real question of whether this administration will successfully argue that birthright citizenship is not, in fact, in the 14th Amendment. And I think that puts a lot of pressure on the document, right? And there's also an argument to be made, and legal scholars have made, that a constitution that has become functionally unamendable lacks legitimacy. I think there is a bit of a crisis of legitimacy to the Constitution, right? There's that. The current document of the Oval Office, he does not know if it's his duty to uphold the Constitution in spite of having
在过去的十年里，行政权发生了巨大的变化，你知道的。三权分立几乎已经完全侵蚀殆尽，虽然不是全部，但也严重侵蚀了。现在有一个真正的问题，那就是本届政府是否能成功地争辩说，出生公民权实际上并不在第十四宪法修正案中。我认为这给这份文件带来了巨大的压力，对吧？而且还有观点认为，正如法律学者所指出的那样，一部实际上无法修正的宪法缺乏合法性。我认为宪法确实存在某种程度的合法性危机，对吧？情况就是这样。现任椭圆形办公室的主人，他甚至不知道尽管自己宣誓要维护宪法，但维护宪法是否还是他的责任。
sworn an oath to do just that. So I think that, I think it's an unsustainable and untenable situation. You hear more about constitutions from AI companies than you do from the general public right now. So I think there's like a pressure point that we are at. I do think there are also a lot of initiatives that are very quiet and sleepy right now, but could await a way. And so one is an organization called Democracy, 2076. It's really a youth organization that's trying to hold citizens' assemblies to get people to talk about, well, it does take forever to change the Constitution. Honestly, it takes about 50 years historically to get an amendment from idea to ratification. So if you could imagine what the Constitution should look like in 2076, what do you want?
发过这样的誓。所以我觉得，我认为这是一种不可持续且站不住脚的局面。你现在从人工智能公司那里听到关于宪法的讨论，甚至比从普通公众那里听到得还要多。所以我认为我们正处于一个压力点。我也确实认为，现在有很多非常安静和沉寂的倡议，但它们可能会等待某种方式。其中之一就是一个名为“2076年民主”的组织。它实际上是一个青年组织，试图举办公民大会，让人门开始讨论——嗯，修改宪法确实需要很长时间。老实说，历史上从提出修正案的想法到最终批准，大约需要50年的时间。所以，如果你能想象一下2076年的宪法应该是什么样子，你希望它是什么样的？
And just to have those conversations because I think kind of freeing up our imagination is. an important thing to do. So I think there's a fair bit of that. I have heard from so many readers who have like amendment ideas. I don't go talk to 2076. I guess I have had and still haven't lost some hope that the hoopla around the 250th, you know, much of which is either jingoistic or silly, could be a way for people to talk a little bit more about constitutionalism. I think there's some real possibility that some states, a number of states have, like every 10 or in some cases 15 years have a question on the ballot, should we hold a constitutional convention? And everyone has said no since 1986 when Rhode Island held one. But we used to have state constitutional
进行这些讨论只是为了释放我们的想象力，这是一件很重要的事情。所以我想这其中有相当一部分内容。我听到了许多读者的心声，他们有很多关于修正案的想法。我没有去跟“2076年民主”交流。我想我曾经有、并且现在也还没有失去一些希望，那就是围绕250周年庆典的喧嚣——你知道，其中很多要么是沙文主义的，要么是愚蠢的——可能会成为人们更多地讨论宪政的一种方式。我认为确实存在某种可能性，一些州，相当一部分州，每隔10年或者在某些情况下15年，选票上就会有一个问题：我们是否应该召开制宪会议？自从1986年罗德岛州召开过一次以来，每个人都投了否定票。但我们过去常常举行各州的制宪
conventions all the time and I think they're really good for civil society. Even if the constitutions don't mean amending, it's fine to just get together and say, yeah, it's all right. Legit as a stat. But I think there's a fair chance that there'll be some state constitutional conventions coming about. So I don't know. I think things are stuck until they're not and the Berlin wall comes down. Yeah. Well, Jillipur, thank you so much for talking with us. Thank you so much. I'm such a fan of your work. I really appreciate your time. Thanks to you both. It's a real honor to be on your show. I really appreciate it. If you want to learn more about constitutional amendments, I highly, highly recommend
会议，而且我认为它们对公民社会真的很有好处。即使这些宪法并不意味着要修改，大家聚在一起说“嗯，挺好的，作为一个州这很合法”，这也很好。但我认为，未来出现一些州级制宪会议的几率还是蛮高的。所以，我不知道。我觉得事情在发生变化之前一直都是停滞不前的，直到柏林墙倒塌。是的。好吧，吉利普，非常感谢你与我们交谈。非常感谢。我是你作品的超级粉丝。非常感谢你抽出时间。谢谢你们俩。能上你们的节目真是我的荣幸。我真的很感激。如果你想了解更多关于宪法修正案的信息，我强烈、强烈推荐
Jillipur's new book, We the People, it is engaging, is funny, is full of fascinating side stories. And if you're into audiobooks, she reads the audiobook herself, and it's just fantastic. Join us next month for the constitutional breakdown of Article 6, which includes the Supremacy Clause and Article 7. The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Constitution is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee, music by Swan Real, mixed by Martine Gonzalez. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Perrube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashamaddon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and Me, Roman Mars. The 99% of its logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
吉利普的新书《我们人民》，这本书引人入胜、妙趣横生，充满了迷人的趣闻轶事。如果你喜欢有声书，她亲自朗读了有声书，效果简直棒极了。欢迎下个月继续收听我们关于第六条（包括至高条款）和第七条的宪法剖析。《99%隐形》宪法剖析节目由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔制作，委员会编辑，斯旺·雷尔配音，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。凯茜·2是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特ッド是数字总监。德兰妮·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。其余团队成员包括克里斯·佩鲁韦、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉沙·马多恩、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、塔林和雷恩·斯特德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是Sirius XM播客大家庭的一部分，总部现在位于潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。
In Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where we have fun discussions about constitutional law, about architecture, about movies, music, all kinds of good stuff. You can find a link to the Discord server as well as every past episode of the Conlaw Book Club and every past episode of 99PI and 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站上找到这个节目，也可以在我们的Discord服务器上找到我们，在那里我们对宪法、建筑、电影、音乐以及各种好东西进行有趣的讨论。你可以找到Discord服务器的链接，以及《宪法法书友会》和《99PI》以及99PI.org的每一期往期节目。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。